we've shared quite a bit on how to break
social media addiction how to break a
smartphone addiction through my series
of videos on digital minimalism but what
about youtube
youtube addiction is very much real so
in this video i'm going to give you 10
tips to help you break your youtube
addiction because we're not all cookie
cutter i did want to give several tips
because our experiences may be different
and so my hope is that you can take the
ones that work for you based on your
personal experience and i think i'm
going to start with like the simple
easier ones for the beginning and then
save the hardcore for those of you who
want to live on the wild side for last
so my hope is that you can take what you
can grab from this and that it will be
helpful for you if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up to help
support my channel and if not by all
means thumbs it down but please give me
some feedback in the comments so that i
know what to work on okay so let's begin
with the most controversial one first
number one unsubscribe from the channels
that don't add value to your life this
sounds so counterintuitive right now
because usually the first thing you hear
on a video is tap that like button hit
that subscribe hit that notification
bell and of course i'd love for you to
subscribe and find value in my videos
and watch my videos but more importantly
than that the videos that you are the
information really that you're consuming
on a daily basis can really shape your
perception and attitude on life so be
mindful of the type of content that
you're consuming we're constantly being
bombarded by information through ads and
commercials but what about the
information that you're consciously
subscribed to
really try to ask yourself first what
kind of a life do you want to live what
are your values what kind of a person do
you want to be really have a clear
vision in your mind and then from there
ask yourself if each of those people or
those channels that you're subscribed to
actually in line with that vision
do they actually provide value to your
life and if not chunk them and say ah
number two along with unsubscribing turn
off notifications this doesn't really
just apply to youtube but really it goes
across the board to all other forms of
social media have you ever been working
on a project and you've been so in the
zone so focused and then you hear that
ding
and you just
you just
have to
have to check it hold on one second your
curiosity is now sparked and even though
you maybe didn't get up to check what it
was
your focus is now gone because your
brain is trying to work so hard to try
to calm down that curiosity or maybe you
actually did get up to check what it was
and now you're completely distracted by
the thing you were working on
what was i working on
oh oh hey
just avoid those situations all together
to avoid going down that rabbit hole
number three is use it only as a search
engine this one i think will be more
helpful for those of you who have
trouble with binge watching the
suggested videos those darn suggested
when i've been asked how i managed to
have balance on youtube i usually
mention that i only use youtube as a
search engine for example my husband and
i recently bought a mock-up and rather
than just seeing reviews online i turned
to youtube to find comparisons and
reviews so i did a quick search on
youtube to help us make this decision
the problem comes when you're finding
yourself lost in the suggested videos on
chrome there's actually an extension
that can help you with this for free
it's called distraction free youtube and
what this does is basically it allows
you to control what you see on youtube
so you it allows you to
only view the video and the comments
themselves without showing you the
suggested videos if you turns out that
you actually don't like this you can
actually go into the settings and tweak
it or just eliminate the extension
altogether so this can give you a really
personalized option depending on what
your preferences are number four use
your phone's screen time trackers or use
an app you can actually do this on
desktop as well but phones are just so
easily accessible that they tend to be
the biggest time suckers so you're
trying to give yourself an hour but the
hour quickly turned into three
four
now it's three am and you have to be up
at five and you don't wanna wake up
groggy so you may as well keep on
scrolling right
i'm totally being sarcastic guys please
don't do that sleep is delicious thumbs
up if you agree if you genuinely have
trouble with limiting your screen time
try using a screen time tracker to set
some limits
there are tons of apps out there and if
you have an iphone like me it's actually
a built-in feature so make use of these
features
number five is actually pretty simple
and it's to delete your search history
if you feel like you don't need some
hardcore or extreme measures but for
some reason those suggested videos just
keep reeling you in
then try deleting your search history
this simple tip can be a big help
youtube recommends videos that are
similar to the ones that you've watched
and have previously enjoyed so if you
really love funny cat videos it will
likely recommend to you more funny cat
videos so just by deleting your search
history it will make it less likely that
you'll have the same types of videos
that have been
endlessly scrolled through
i actually had to do this when my
husband grabbed a hold of my phone to
watch how to replace some thingamajig on
our vehicle and all of a sudden i was
getting recommended all sorts of
automotive and car videos and
i'm sorry but i'm just not interested
tip number six schedule it i think that
this tip can be especially helpful for
those of you who have guilt when it
comes to time wasted on a screen as a
working mom sometimes i do just want to
get on my phone and watch awesome recipe
videos of things that i'm probably never
going to cook but if i'm on my phone
when i could have for example been
reading a book with my daughter then i
end up feeling guilty because i know
that my time could have been better
spent if you really enjoy watching dr
pimple popper but there's certain things
that you really need to get done that
you shouldn't procrastinate on then try
having a designated time designated hour
of the day when you can give yourself
permission to have that unproductive
scrolling time and only do it during
this time i mean sometimes you do just
want to have unproductive time to
consume content and that's okay but
ideally it shouldn't be for hours on end
seven days a week so try to find what a
good time frame could be and schedule a
date with yourself but just don't go
past your time think of it like an
appointment this can be helpful even if
your time is productive for example
answering youtube comments or watching
some free exam prep lessons
ah my classmates paid so much money for
their nursing exam prep lessons
but youtube has them for free
technology can be great there are so
many things that we can learn at the
touch of our fingertips but be smart
about when you're actually doing these
things
[Music]
like maybe not at 9pm when you're about
to get ready for bed
i love this next one number seven find a
different hobby or passion project
sometimes we look to our screens when we
have downtime because we feel bored or
we feel like we have nothing better to
do but this can be a really vicious
cycle because consuming so much
information constantly can really rob
you of your creativity so then you end
up feeling like you have nothing better
to do or nothing else to do but to
consume more content we all have
creativity within us but we end up
losing that drive that creative vision
that we had when we were kids because of
the way that we live our lives and the
expectations we have placed by society
my dad is very much a workaholic and he
proudly admits it but by the same token
he's also told me that he's worked so
hard for so long that he doesn't have
any other hobbies at this point he
doesn't know what else he would do with
his time except for work if you feel
like you have no other hobbies besides
youtube then perhaps try starting by
replacing it with something that at
least stretches your mind or betters
your health overall in some way like
reading books going for walks listening
to audiobooks or motivational podcasts
or maybe just go outside get yourself a
bubble gun and go outside and pop some
bubbles just cuz
when i first quit social media years
back one of the things that i used to do
when i would get bored was decluttering
while listening to audiobooks and oddly
enough the physical act of decluttering
my space really improved my mental state
overall and mixing that with audiobooks
was perfect for me because as i was
getting rid of the excess in my life i
was also improving my mindset to make
positive changes in my life
so if you have a hobby try getting back
to it if you don't have one then start
by learning new things you will find the
hobbies along the way
tip number nine make your phone less
accessible when i go out anywhere my
phone is always with me it is a must but
when i'm around the house it has a
designated home where it lives when i'm
not using it i place it in our mailbox
keyholder thingamajig and if i need it
then i grab a hold of it and once i'm
finished back in it's home it goes
it doesn't follow me around the house
all day and if i'm changing my baby's
diaper and i don't return your call in
about three minutes then
okay
i think that doing this alone has really
helped ease my sense of urgency when i
get a text message or a phone call
because fomo is a big part of social
media addiction but i talked
specifically about that in my video why
i quit social media but for me i really
think that just having my phone
physically away from me has been a big
help in having a healthy balance with it
because it's not an extension of me it's
not like an extremity it's not always
with me so i really recommend having a
home for your phone and that's during
the day but night time as well i
remember the days in high school when i
used to sleep with my phone under my
pillow
ugh the dependency i had with that thing
is just sad my husband and i actually
place our phone on the other end of the
bedroom when we sleep at night and i
love this for two reasons yes it makes
it to where we don't have notifications
easily accessible we have silent mode
anyway but we love that it forces us to
get out of the bed in the morning to
turn off our alarms tip number nine and
a half is to make the app less
accessible if you find yourself
constantly on your phone checking
youtube because well your phone is
always with you then try deleting the
app from your phone
this will make it to where you have to
wait until you get a chance to sit down
on your desktop to be able to use it
instead of you know at the store
checkout line or at work which i know
we're not doing right tip number 10 make
use of the other technology that you
have
okay this one sounds counterproductive
but hear me out if a trigger for you is
that you go to call someone or google
something and then you already have your
phone so you may as well check what's
new on youtube then try to use the
technology that you already have to
avoid this loop altogether for example
if you have an alexa or a siri then try
using these things as much as you can
instead of physically grabbing your
phone i currently work as a nurse in the
home setting and i'm constantly on the
phone with pharmacies and clinics and
families etc and one of the things that
i found helpful for me is that i have
airpods and honestly i thought that
maybe that would make me more dependent
on technology but it's actually been
quite the contrary because it allows me
to be physically detached from my phone
if that makes any sense so for you if
you find a temptation to scroll through
your phone to have it physically with
you then maybe try using other
technology that you may have like if you
have an apple watch or certain things
like that try using the technology that
you have that will allow you to use the
screen less
hey siri turn on my mellow playlist on
spotify now playing on spotify but
please note i'm not telling you to go
buy some technology i'm just telling you
to use the things that you already have
to your advantage and my bonus tip for
you would be to look inward are you
looking to youtube or other social media
outlets to escape or avoid confronting
something that you're going through a
stress a fear a loss or feelings that
you want to hide from if you feel stuck
in your life lonely or depressed are you
using social media as a way to distract
yourself from what's really going on
inside
i encourage you to look within you are
not a victim of your circumstances you
can decide to change your life and live
your best life
today
i think that the tips that i've given
you may be fine and dandy but if the
root of the problem is something that's
been boiling inside you they're not
gonna help one bit that's just masking
the problem it's like painting over a
moldy house and expecting it to go away
it won't so focus on creating
experiences and memories i assure you
that 20 years from now you're not going
to remember the time that you spent
scrolling on youtube but you will
remember those memories that you've
created with your friends and your
family in short i am not saying that
technology is evil technology can do
amazing things i mean microwaved oatmeal
can be done much faster than if you were
to cook it
well i mean i guess you could stick it
in the fridge overnight but you get my
point we now have the power to do things
like say hey siri turn off my lamp i've
mentioned that i work in hospice and for
me that means that the entire goal in my
job is to help people live their best
life for as long as they have it despite
their diseases and their ailments and my
patients and my families have taught me
a whole lot more than i have done for
them and one of those things that i can
share with you is that your computer
your phone your car it's all wonderful
stuff but it's not something you're
gonna care about on your deathbed all
you truly have is time time to create
memories time to make a difference time
to give back and leave this world just a
little bit better so be conscious of the
time that you have and how you're using
it i thank you so much for watching this
video and for giving me your time and my
challenge to you today is to leave this
video and actually go see the people
around you notice their expressions
notice the nature around you
savor it enjoy it go out there and enjoy
your life until next time bye
[Music]